paying tribute to the dead mourners in
Prague have left candles and flowers in
front of the Charles University
philosophy building after what's thought
to be the worst mass shooting in the
country's history here because I'm a
part of uh Charles University members
and it uh touched me very dear at this
horrible situation what happened
yesterday so I felt that I had to come
and feel with the victims of this attack
body cam footage released by police on
Friday shows officers clearing the area
and storming the building where a
24-year-old gunman had opened fire
killing more than a dozen people among
them fellow students he then went to the
balcony where he shot at bystanders
outside and injured three
people as we arrived the gunman felt the
news tightening and made the usual
decision in these cases which is
suicide
police say the attack does not appear to
have been ideologically motivated the
gunman did not have a police record but
police had already been searching for
him after his father was found dead
earlier on Thursday they now think he is
also behind the killing of a father and
baby from the 15th of December the Czech
government has declared Saturday a
national day of
mourning camil nelc Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer